I mean gravity of course is something
that has well many people have already
thought about it it's something that we
see every day and it's not like it's not
existent in our every life but what I
mean by that it's an illusion is that
one would eventually like to know where
it comes from an explanation up to now
we have well descriptions I mean Newton
of course is the one famous for first
writing down a theory of gravity and he
could describe why apples fall and and
why the moon goes around the earth using
the same basic equation for gravity but
he described it he had to assume that
gravity was there and then then had to
write down a law that described it when
two masses are at a certain distance how
they attract each other but he was also
not very happy with the fact that he
should just assume that these things
these objects attract each other and
without even anything in between so if
there are two masses in empty space
there's no nothing that that really
happens between them but Silda they're
attracting each other and he thought
that was kind of mysterious and that it
was something he would have had like to
explain in a better way
so later came in Stein and Einstein with
his theory of relativity eventually
realized that also gravity has to be
described in a different way and it took
him quite some years but then eventually
he wrote down a theory where he thought
about a space and time together and then
his explanation of what gravity would be
is that there's masses which curved
space and time and then the motion of
planets and of the earth around the moon
or the moon around the earth is then
described by thinking about moving in
this curved space-time and how then
objects are are well making their orbits
and the reason they go around then in
circles is that that space and time
itself is curved in the sense that
things don't move in straight lines
anymore they they they go around
so that was his explanation but he had
to write down equation for it which
again assumed that gravity is there
because he basically wrote down that
that the matter occurs the space-time so
in a certain way that's still in the
script
description or what I should say is well
one would like to understand again why
this description sort of how you can can
understand it from a more basic point of
view so what I've done in my paper is
try to start from a formal point of view
where you don't assume gravity to be
there you would like to explain it by
seeing how you can derive it from a more
microscopic set of equations where
gravity itself is not assumed but then
just follows from a certain logical
reasoning
if you think about particles very tiny
particles and it turns out that things
like positions and velocities are not
very precisely defined you have to take
into account effect that there's an
uncertainty in when we look at something
we may influence the measurement but we
may also just doesn't a fundamental
limit on how precise you can understand
the position or the velocity of a
particle they cannot be of all not both
describes infinitely precise so taking
gravity into account then gives us a bit
of a problem because then we have to
talk about space-time and and then these
quantum uncertainties gives us
another way of looking at space-time at
the short distances so this led to
problems and string theory is another
way of also looking at gravity and
quantum mechanics which have been
working on quite a bit so people have
studied the problem of quantum gravity
quantum mechanics and gravity from
various perspective from string theory
but also by thinking for instance about
black holes what happens with black
holes and I've taken some of the things
we've learned about it and seen that
there is some explanation of maybe where
gravity then comes from from those are
new way of thinking about quantum
mechanics and gravity together so if you
then start trying to explain where it
comes from it has to do with the fact
that is at the microscopic scale a
certain information about how you
describe this which we don't see
ourselves we forget about that and it
turns out that if you take that into
account in some appropriate way that you
can understand where where gravity comes
from
the theory that that Einstein wrote down
when you apply it for instance to these
black holes you see that it starts
resembling things that we call
thermodynamics that's a theory that
describes how gases move when they give
them a temperature or when when there is
pressure and you well you can apply it
in very many situations but it's some
way in which we describe how things
happen at very large fairly large scales
in terms of not looking at the
individual motion of the atoms and
molecules but by just thinking about
these objects like temperature pressure
and so on which are what I call
macroscopic quantities mean the
temperature is something that is just an
average of all of the motions or the
collision little collisions of atoms
today for instance on my skin if I think
about what temperature I feel that says
something about the average energy that
each of the molecules in the air is
carrying so temperature is not really a
microscopic thing I can define and so
gravity is somewhat like that in the
sense that the thing the equations that
we currently use to describe gravity are
basically obtained from averaging or at
least describing things as a much tinier
scale and then forgetting about a
certain details so temperature for
instance also forgets about how all of
the individual molecules are moving we
don't have to keep track of that but
still we can describe quite well how
gases move when we just talk about
pressure and temperature and even
differences in pressure for instance
then if you have one room with one
pressure and other room with lower
pressure you simply know that the gas
will flow from one to the other and this
kind of differences is then necessary to
get things moving
it's fun too
about things like gravity and even while
what I had in my paper things like even
the laws of Newton because they do play
a role in one's everyday life but it's
surprising that when I go and walk out
the door and something like that it's
not like I immediately sort of think
about these things in a different way
but for me I think it's more important
eventually what will be the implications
for understanding not just gravity but
also what's happening in the universe I
mean the gravity equations of Einstein
are also used in in describing the
expansion of the universe the Big Bang
Theory are all based on these same
equations what I hope is that that idea
is that that we are now starting to
develop for for gravity can eventually
sort of lead to possibly some somewhat
better or even more refined way of
thinking about the early universe and I
think that will influence a little bit
more by thinking then yeah I think as
human beings we like to know where we
come from and how the universal of sort
of developed into what it's now and
there I think eventually this will will
have some impact